[Musik]
sprunghafter anstieg der korona zahlen
gesundheitsminister sparen waren vor
unkontrollierte ausbreitung tv duell
diesmal mit argumenten die potenziellen
us vize präsidenten kamera harris und
mike pence im schlagabtausch
und auf dem weg zur titelverteidigung
das doppel kevin krawietz und andreas
mies steht wieder im endspiel der french
open
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten haben dann
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert jemand für den sportkreis
einander von mir
angesichts stark steigender corona
zahlen appellieren der chef des robert
koch instituts und der
gesundheitsminister eindringlich an alle
bundesbürger gemeinsam aufzupassen und
die schutzregeln weiter einzuhalten
damit es nicht zu einem moment komme so
jens spahn wo wir die kontrolle
verlieren
das robert koch institut meldet heute
erstmals seit monaten wieder über 4000
neuinfektionen gestern waren es noch
unter 3000 das allein sei aber nicht
entscheidend betont ergo-chef wähler
wichtig sei auch die zahl schwerer
krankheitsverläufe oder die belegung der
intensivstationen thomas konsum wird das
ein unbeschwerter herbst oder einer mit
noch mehr masken pflicht und noch mehr
abstand
das robert koch institut mit gedämpfter
stimmung das infektionsgeschehen nimmt
in fast allen regionen zu und das meine
damen und herren das macht mir große
sorgen sorgen warum infizieren sich
nicht eher jüngere die dann kaum
erkrankten nein das ändert sich gerade
sagt das rk infizierte waren im april im
schnitt 52 jahre alt im august nur 32
dann ging es wieder hoch 38 jahre alt
sind angesteckte jetzt im schnitt und
wieder mehr ältere menschen erkranken
auch schwer nach der hochphase der
pandemie blieb die zahl der
intensivpatienten mit gleichbleibend
dann stieg sie 487 menschen sind auf
intensivstationen die hälfte davon wird
beatmet
warum aber steigen die zahlen rk ii
diagnose zu viele sind immer noch zu
arglos denn corona schien im sommer
harmlos
einige behaupten das zeige dass das
virus doch nicht so gefährlich sei das
ist ein trugschluss
es sind nicht so viele menschen erkannt
und gestorben weil wir gemeinsam
maßnahmen ergriffen haben und uns daran
gehalten haben vorsichtsmassnahmen die
zu weniger vorsicht führen ein paradox
wirksamstes rezept so das lka die aha
regeln weiter beachten abstand hygiene
alltags maske und entlüften regelmäßig
immerhin gestiegen ist auch eine weitere
zahl die der tests 1,2 millionen pro
woche aktuell drei mal so viele wie zur
corona hochphase laut experten eine gute
basis um zu schauen wo wird der herbst
zwanglos und wo wird das leben
eingeschränkt von einem möglichen
zweiten lockdown will
gesundheitsminister sparen nicht reden
schließlich gelinge mit
schutzvorkehrungen in vielen bereichen
ein normaler betrieb
es gebe keine ausbrüche beim einkaufen
bei friseuren kaum welche im nahverkehr
auch in schulen sei die lage insgesamt
gut im griff
kritisch seien feiern und
veranstaltungen daniel thompson hat mehr
für ihn ist es eine gratwanderung der
neuerliche anstieg der infektionszahlen
sorge ihn zugleich höre er immer
häufiger den vorwurf es gebe eine zu
große fokussierung auf diese zahl der
neuinfektionen was auch er ablehne
es gibt halt ein hohes bedürfnis und das
verstehe ich auch das habe ich
persönlich im zweifel auch das alles auf
eine zahl oder einen parameter zu
reduzieren das ist aber zu komplex und
dem möchte ich einfach entgegentreten er
mit dem hinweis dass wir das jeden tag
auch darstellen und einordnen in dieser
in dieser breite und in diesen diesen
abhängigkeiten gesundheitswesen intensiv
kapazität sterbefälle hospitalisierung
wichtig sei dass regeln nachvollziehbar
und einheitlich sein
gilt das fragen wie auf norderney für
das gestern von kanzleramt und ländern
beschlossene beherbergungs verbotes nun
vielerorts gilt für menschen ohne
negativen test aus regionen mit mehr als
50 neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
wohnen wollten jetzt natürlich gerne
wissen ob sie nun anreisen dürfen oder
nicht was ich ihnen jetzt leider ja auch
nicht erst mal nicht mitteilen konnte
das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd dann
auch einheitlich sind die regeln nicht
thüringen etwa schied aus weil sich die
pandemie weitaus glimpflicher entwickelt
habe als zunächst befürchtet seien die
neuen regeln und sinn
ich bin am 12 märz diesen jahres von
60.000 schwerst erkrankten als option
ausgegangen und habe auf dieser basis
den lockdown mitgetragen und ich finde
ihn nach wie vor wichtig dass wir im
märz das so gemacht haben heute haben
wir nicht einmal 4500 infizierte
personen in ganz thüringen gaben bayerns
ministerpräsident hält die regeln
dagegen für angemessen
wer mit einem negativen test anreist der
kann ein urlaub genießen aber wer zum
beispiel keinen test macht oder werden
infiziert ist da glaube ich ist es ja
nur sinnvoll dass man diese
vorsichtsmaßnahmen für alle trifft
grundlegend unterschiedliche bewertungen
die einheitliche regelung womöglich auch
künftig erschweren unsere nachbarländer
kämpfen noch mit deutlich schneller
steigenden corona zahlen frankreich
meldet innerhalb von 24 stunden mehr als
18.000 neuansteckungen die
vergleichsweise kleinen niederlande
haben mit 5800 neuinfektionen einen
neuen höchststand
in italien gilt seit heute eine masken
pflicht im freien
bei verstößen drohen geldstrafen bis zu
1000 euro
nur beim sport muss keine maske getragen
werden sprunghafte anstieg corona zahlen
steigen die sorge wächst heißt ein zdf
spezial direkt nach uns wichtige details
gibt es auch in der heute app zum
beispiel eine karte wo sie nachschauen
können wie sich die infektionszahlen in
ihrer region entwickeln bis ende des
jahres hat deutschland den eu
ratsvorsitz eine einigung auf eine
reform des eu asylrechts bis dahin wäre
ein riesenerfolg und so innenminister
seehofer für die handlungsfähigkeit
europas entscheidend bei den beratungen
mit seinen eu-kollegen heute setzte er
sich für den entwurf der kommission ein
länder die keine flüchtlinge aufnehmen
sollen anderer tisch helfen
anne gellinek berichtet ein blick auf
die griechische insel samos reicht um zu
verstehen was an europas asylsystem
nicht funktioniert das lager das für 600
menschen geplant war ist hoffnungslos
überfüllt auf engstem raum
zusammengepfercht warten flüchtlinge oft
jahre auf einen asylbescheid und hoffen
auf eine zukunft in europa europas
innenminister debattieren am vormittag
zum ersten mal die neuen asyl pläne der
eu-kommission für videokonferenz- kern
der vorschläge ist ein verbesserter
schutz der eu-außengrenzen schnellere
asylverfahren und eine effektivere
abschiebung
statt einer pflichtquote zur verteilung
von flüchtlingen sollen die
mitgliedstaaten künftig wählen dürfen ob
sie migranten aufnehmen oder sich um die
abschiebung abgelehnter asylbewerber
kümmern wollen kritik an den plänen
kommt aus südeuropa den sogenannten
ankunfts ländern
ich verstehe ihre sorgen die sorge
mündet in dem satz wir bleiben dann auf
allen zuwanderern in unseren ländern
sitzen weil es kann die solidarität
außer hingibt in europa und weil die
rückführung in die herkunftsstaaten
nicht richtig funktioniert die sorge ist
berechtigt denn osteuropäische länder
sowie österreich lehnen den plan bislang
ab sie kritisieren den vorschlag dass
länder die die abschiebung von migranten
nicht fristgerecht durchführen diese
dann aufnehmen müssten
das sei eine quote durch die hintertür
schon die erste vorsichtige debatte über
den migrations pakt war lang und
schwierig ein drittel der
mitgliedstaaten lehnt den plan in teilen
ab viele andere haben zweifel
der deutsche innenminister und
ratspräsident hat jetzt die aufgabe den
wohl schwierigsten konflikte europas bis
jahresende zu lösen
das ist ein sehr ehrgeiziger plan in den
usa kämpfen zwei männer ums weiße haus
die jeweils auf die 80 zu gehen
da ist es für viele amerikaner durchaus
auch entscheidend wer das amt des
vize-präsidenten bekommt und
möglicherweise auch übernehmen muss
amtsinhaber mike pence und die
demokratische bewerberin kamala harris
trafen jetzt erstmals im tv duell
aufeinander
die wähler sahen eine ziemlich gesittete
debatte ohne entgleisungen ganz anders
als bei donald trump und joe biden vor
einer woche aus washington jutta sonne
wald es gibt nur diese eine debatte der
stellvertreter und die findet unter
strengen sicherheitsvorkehrungen statt
knapp vier meter und plexiglasscheiben
trennen den vize-präsidenten mike pence
und kanada harris voneinander
es geht um rassismus das
gesundheitswesen und vor allem um corona
es ist wohl das größte versagen einer
amerikanischen regierung in der
geschichte unseres landes am 28 januar
wussten der vizepräsident und der
präsident über die gefahr dieser
pandemie
sie wussten es und haben es verschleiert
fans der die korona task force im weißen
haus leitet macht dagegen china für das
virus verantwortlich und luftraums
krisen management in der pandemie
wenn der präsident nicht den einmaligen
schritt unternommen hätte etwa die
hälfte der amerikanischen wirtschaft zu
schließen hätten wir rund 2,2 millionen
amerikanische leben verloren
die debatte zwischen vize mike pence und
der senatorin kamalla harris verläuft
ruhiger und zivilisierter als die
zwischen trump und beiden doch auch
penns feld harris immer wieder ins wort
per vizepräsident jetzt spreche ich bei
dieser tv debatte geht es auch um das
ankurbeln der wirtschaft steuern und die
klimapolitik
unterschiedlicher könnten die positionen
nicht sein fracking und fossile
brennstoffe abschaffen den energiesektor
zerstören und wirtschaftlich gegenüber
china kapitulieren das ist ein rezept
für wirtschaftlichen niedergang
wir werden sieben millionen mehr neue
jobs schaffen als donald trumps
regierung ein teil dieser jobs wird im
bereich sauberer erneuerbarer sie will
die erste schwarze vize-präsidentin
amerikas werden er seinen posten
behalten
laut umfragen hält eine mehrheit der
amerikaner kamalla harris für die
gewinnerin dieser debatte wenn man auch
die umfragen schau zeigt sich dass auch
der präsident immer weiter zurückfällt
elmar theveßen in washington donald
trump liegt derzeit zweistellig hinter
joe biden
wie will er das ruder rumreißen
er will vor allen dingen raus haben die
basis sein team plant derzeit mehrere
kundgebungen in der kommenden woche vor
tausenden von anhängern
obwohl medizinische experten sagen dass
der präsident durchaus noch ansteckend
sein könnte
zu diesem zeitpunkt wird wahrscheinlich
doch auch eine debatte haben mit joe
biden
man hat sich darauf verständigt dass es
wohl eine woche verschiebung geben
könnte für die nächste debatte aber
wegen seines erratischen verhaltens
wegen seiner schimpftiraden und auch
wegen der fehlenden rücksicht auf die
eigenen mitarbeiter wächst ein stück
weit der unmut auch die verzweiflung
innerhalb der republikanischen partei
und hatte angst vor einer so genannten
blauen welle also dass nicht nur das
weiße haus hier hinter uns sondern auch
beide kammern des kongresses an die
demokraten gehen könnten in der wahl in
einer art erdrutschsieg und je
schlechter die aussichten für donald
trump auf seine wiederwahl sind desto
mehr so befürchten sogar mitglieder
seiner eigenen partei führende
mitglieder könnte er chaos säen wollen
um dann hinterher
nach dem dritten november die wahl
ergebnisse anzuzweifeln
die einschätzung unseres usa
korrespondenten matti wissen vielen dank
dafür
zurück nach berlin einen rechtsanspruch
auf home office wird das wohl so schnell
nicht geben
bundeskanzlerin merkel lehnt den entwurf
von arbeitsminister heil spd ab der will
ein anrecht auf 24 tage zu hause
arbeiten pro jahr
da gebe es noch viel gesprächsbedarf
sagte merkel auf einer veranstaltung des
handwerks sowie von heyl vorgelegt werde
das gesetz in dieser legislaturperiode
nicht mehr durch den bundestag kommen
hans-georg maßen früher chef des
verfassungsschutzes musste heute im
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
aussagen
es ging um die frage ob er und seine
behörde den attentäter eines amri falsch
eingeschätzt haben
mit einem lastwagen war der islamist im
dezember 2016 in den weihnachtsmarkt am
berliner breitscheidplatz gerast zwölf
menschen starben aus berlin florian a
vor fast zwei jahren wurde hans-georg
maßen vom chefposten des
verfassungsschutzes abberufen heute holt
in seiner amtszeit noch mal ein
zeugenaussage vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss zum anschlag am
breitscheidplatz 2016 zur frage was
wusste der verfassungsschutz
herr dr maßen war nachweislich der
einzige behördenchef der den namen anis
ambri vor dem anschlag kannte und ein
behörden zeugt es unterzeichnet hat ein
dokument das der ausschuss zu tage
förderte januar 2016 die schriftliche
warnung amri wolle mitstreiter für
anschläge gewinnen unterzeichnet von
hans-georg maßen dabei hatte maßen stets
beteuert bei ambri habe es sich um einen
reinen polizei fall gehandelt der
nachrichtendienst also nicht eingebunden
die fakten die wir gesehen haben und die
zeugenaussagen die wir gehört haben in
fast zweieinhalb jahren
die sprechen eine andere sprache der
verfassungsschutz war sehr früh dran an
anis amri vor dem ausschuss bleibt maßen
bei seiner these ambri hätte zwar früher
abgeschoben werden müssen dass er bei
seien nicht sache des
verfassungsschutzes
die verantwortung liegt nicht ich sage
mal beim feuerwerk männern
wenn ein feuer ausbricht und die
feuerwehrmänner im falle an ist amri
waren die polizeibehörden und die
verfassungsschutzbehörden es lag nicht
an ihn sei es lag an anderen und es lag
an der politik also das ist ein von sich
weisen von verantwortung was wir so
nicht akzeptieren können aber offenbar
ein muster das im ausschuss seit beginn
der untersuchungsarbeit ständig begegnet
hans-georg maßen macht heute keine
ausnahme wer etwas über den alltag in
der ddr lernen wolle der solle die
bücher von günter de bruyn lesen hat
angela merkel einmal gesagt jetzt ist
der schriftsteller im alter von 93
jahren gestorben
seine themen macht und ohnmacht liebe
und verrat und immer wieder das leben in
der sed diktatur und die kritik an den
zuständen dort nach der wende
hinterfragte er sein eigenes verhalten
damals in den autobiographien
zwischenbilanz und 40 jahre
der nobelpreis für literatur geht in
diesem jahr an eine autorin die wohl
viele leser
in deutschland noch nicht entdeckt haben
die amerikanische lyrikerin louis blick
die für ihre gedichte in den usa schon
viele preise und ehrungen erhalten hat
auch von präsident obama das werk der 77
jährigen sei aufrichtig und
kompromisslos aber auch voller humor und
beißendem schaffen so die begründung
ihre erste reaktion erst habe sie panik
bekommen dann gedacht sie halluzinieren
millionen singles 10 nicht nur in corona
zeiten hier eine echte chance mit hilfe
von online agenturen wie parship oder
elite einen partner zu finden
wer sich dort anmeldet muss einiges
investieren und zwar selbst dann wenn er
oder sie nach wenigen tagen den vertrag
wieder kündigen will das geht so nicht
entschied heute der europäische
gerichtshof birgit franke hat details
sie wecken viele hoffnungen die
schwesterunternehmen parship und
elitepartner
daher hat auch die toto sich bei
letzterem angemeldet mitgliedsbeitrag
insgesamt 455 euro für zwei jahre
nach 14 tagen wieder ruft sie fristgemäß
den vertrag weil ich eben sehr viel
unpassende sexuelle angebote bekommen
habe die ich mir halt bei so einer
kostenpflichtigen partnerbörse nicht
erhofft hatte dann die böse überraschung
knapp 240 euro soll sie für die
angebotenen leistungen zahlen jutta
depot kein einzelfall
die beiden singlebörsen verlangen bei
widerruf bis zu 75 prozent vom
gesamtbetrag doch der bgh stellt heute
klar
kunden müssen nur anteilig die tage bis
zum widerruf zahlen wenn sie ein
gesamtpaket gebucht haben
ein beispiel wer einen vertrag mit einem
jahresbeitrag von 400 euro abschließt
und nach vier tagen wieder ruft zahlt
rund 4 eur 40 verbraucherschützer
begrüßen das klare urteil
wir empfehlen denjenigen die innerhalb
der letzten drei jahre so ein vertrag
widerrufen haben sich das geld was sie
zu viel bezahlt haben zurückzuholen
nach dem urteil heute teilt uns parship
mit dass sie ihre berechnungen nun
anpassen 801 und ab
die verfahren laufen derzeit noch vor
gericht als partner erfolgreich zeigen
sich zwei deutsche herren im tennis
doppel stehen wieder in paris
kevin krawietz und andreas mies die sind
einfach nicht zu stoppen wieder ein
starker auftritt der titelverteidiger
diesmal gegen die us open finalisten
wesley kolhoff und nicola match am ende
ein souveräner zweisatzsieg als es
vollbracht ist muss die ganze anspannung
raus kevin krawietz und andreas mies
zeigen knapp anderthalb stunden doppelt
tennis auf höchstem niveau sicher von
der grundlinie und sehr präsent vorne am
netz
wenn wir unser bestes tennis so auf den
platz kriegen dann ist das extrem
unangenehm gegen uns und das haben wir
gezeigt von anfang bis ende das match
beginnt und endet mit einem break für
die deutschen
6 3 und 7 5 jetzt fehlt nur noch ein
sieg zur titelverteidigung am samstag
gegen das kroatische brasilianische
doppel pavic so harisch schon wieder nur
ein unentschieden trotz dreimaliger
führung gegen die türkei am samstag
setzt bundestrainer löw beim nations
league spiel in der ukraine auf
bayern-stars plus toni kroos und timo
werner die devise nicht nochmals sieglos
so wie gestern abend seine laune nach
dem spiel nicht schwer zu ergründen beim
sportlich bedeutungslosen test erst die
ordnung dann die kontrolle verloren und
spät den ausgleich kassiert das ergebnis
macht uns natürlich alle auch und
angefressen klar wenn man drei mal führt
die zweite garde mit neuling und
torschütze neuhaus engagiert doch wie
schon in den spielen zuvor
das team bringt eine führung nicht über
die zeit das bundes in den nächsten
tagen natürlich auch mal thematisiert
vor dem ukrainisch spiel um dann einfach
auch in zukunft aus solchen situationen
dann auch
zu lernen nach zuletzt drei
unentschieden gibt es nun eine interne
aussprache
sie dürfte unbequem werden gleich zwei
leichtathletik weltrekorde auf der
langstrecke gestern abend in valencia
die thesen bett die idee aus äthiopien
über 5000 meter 14 minuten und 6,62
sekunden
sie blieb damit vier sekunden unter der
alten rekordmarke und joscha chip.de aus
uganda der knackte den 15 jahre alten
weltrekord über 10.000 meter in 26
minuten und 11 sekunden
er war fast acht sekunden schneller und
ungefähr 30 minuten schneller als ich
ich brauche inzwischen bereits länger
über die zehn kilometer nicht schlimm
wir haben noch eine nachricht zum
schluss die gewicht hat ein
ausgewachsener see elefantenbulle hat in
chile einen unfreiwilligen ausflug durch
ein dorf gemacht und zwei tonnen bringt
das tier auf die waage alles andere als
leicht auch die rettungsaktion dutzende
menschen versuchten mit planen den
koloss wieder richtung meer zu geleiten
erfolgreich unter applaus verschwand er
schließlich im wasser seinem natürlichen
lebensraum
das wetter bringt morgen im norden sonne
im süden sonne und dazwischen regen mehr
gleich von katja honnefer bettina
schausten freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um 10 und hier übernimmt morgen
petra gerster
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren heute beehrte uns
das tief des erst kam die warmfront und
dann hinterher auch die kaltfront und so
hat es doch vor allen dingen in
norddeutschland geregelt aber nicht nur
dort in den vergangenen drei tagen kamen
deutschlandweit 1 bis 50 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammen und am meisten
regen fiel im schwarzwald und jetzt in
der nacht fällt noch weiterer regen denn
die kleine kaltfront zieht südwärts und
erreicht bis zum frühen morgen die sa
und das erzgebirge unter dieser
kaltfront platz in der nacht recht mild
da sinken die temperaturen auf 13 bis 10
grad sonst gibt es häufig einstellige
werte und am kühlsten wird es am
alpenrand mit vier grad
die kaltfront zieht dann morgen über tag
weiter nach süden erreicht dann später
auch die schwäbische alb und den
oberpfälzer wald dann kommen von der
nordsee neue regenschauer heran
zwischendurch aber bleibt doch auch ganz
gut platz für die sonne nämlich zwischen
der ostseeküste und dem emsland und auch
südlich der donau und dort wird es bevor
die kalte und an kommt nochmal recht mit
da steigen morgen die werte auf 17 bis
20 grad sonst sind es nur 13 bis 16 grad
und sehr wechselhaft und windig geht's
in den nächsten tagen weiter dabei wird
es auch wieder
schönen abend noch